I think it's time to begin to talk very
very frankly about the forest
engineering of consciousness about the
we shaman iesson of society about the
beefer of archaic values before it's too
late if we do this I really believe that
we primates love the scrap and that it's
not too late it's just almost too late
we are like someone awakening in the
stupor in a burning house it's time to
stagger out on for the front lawn and
sort things out we're going to be crispy
critters think we don't get our act
together so I want to urge each of you
to consider yourself self selected to be
here tonight and therefore potentially
an ambassador for reason on this issue
of consciousness expansion and self
exploration this is how religion was
practiced for the first million years of
its existence it was only later that men
wearing dresses took over the operation
and I've been shoving it down
everybody's throat in a very unpleasant
for ever since the Gaia matrix is there
psychedelics more we're not talking
about sweeping up around the ashram for
12 years before somebody gives you the
Goulet this stuff works and if you have
taken five dried grounds tonight in the
confines of your home instead of coming
here you would be there now so it
a tool which works it doesn't it isn't
controlled by any b-behind
faction though with a bunch of
mumbo-jumbo around it it is self
directed self-explanatory and anyone who
loves adventure and loves life and loves
the experience of being has an
obligation I think to explore this it's
as much a part of your identity as your
sexuality your ancestral history or your
hopes and fears and to ignore it is to
choose to play with less than a full
dinner don't do that
play little all day helped launch the
Millennium let's save the planet and
create a world that we can be proud to
hand on to our children thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]